so let me start have the pleasure of
introducing very briefly demis hassabis
and this is continuing a tradition that
I started with Christophe is a much
better known that I am and he was a
postdoc with me Davis and and of course
is ideal for today because is a mixture
of a neuroscientist and a technologist
and an entrepreneur echo it so it's
great to be here
okay we'll hear me yeah so so I'm going
to talk a little bit about because of
the symposiums about neuroscience and
brains and minds as well as machines I'm
going to focus sort of most of my talk
around systems neuroscience and how it
can be maybe helpful towards further in
helping us progress in our quest for
building AI so I'm the CEO of deepmind
deep mine was founded in 2010 and then
we joined forces in Google in 2014 to
sort of accelerate progress towards our
mission of solving intelligence one way
you can think about deep mind is a kind
of like an Apollo program effort for AI
so we have over 150 research scientists
now so I think it's the largest
collection anywhere of sort of machine
learning researchers on this single
topic but also one of the things we try
to do with the mind is come up with a
new approach to organizing and doing
science so we've tried to combine and
take the best from the best academic
Institute's and combine that with what's
best form you know the greatest sort of
Silicon Valley style startups and we try
to kind of create a hybrid environment
that maximizes and it's sort of
optimized for research progress to try
and make it as efficient and productive
and collaborative as possible
so what we do at the moment we're sort
of interested in algorithms we call them
general-purpose learning algorithms and
we're only really interesting algorithms
that can learn automatically from raw
inputs or directly from walk experience
so are not pre-programmed or handcrafted
in any way and we're also interested in
this notion of generality so the idea
that the set of same single system or
single set of algorithms can operate out
of the box across a wide range of tasks
and in fact this relates to our
operational definition if you like of
intelligence that we use at deep mind
which is we define it as the ability to
perform well across a wide range of
environments so while I agree with Tommy
and I think of some of the other
speakers today about the intelligences
quite an amorphous term we found that
operationalizing it like this and
putting generality at the center of it
works very well for us and you could
argue well what about all these
different properties that that doesn't
cover you know creativity etc but
actually then it just depends on the
tasks that you include in the set of
tasks that you're going to try and
attempt so the wider and the more
diverse the better so we call this type
of AI artificial general intelligence or
AGI and the hallmark of this kind of
these kinds of algorithms is that
they're flexible and adaptive and
perhaps even one day inventive and
they're built to feel with the
unexpected from the beginning now
contrast that with a lot of what's
called AI out there which we mostly term
narrow AI which is often hand crafts
doodle special case for specific problem
and therefore can be very brittle if
something unexpected happens it will
just catastrophic see fail so one of the
other sort of philosophies I guess that
we commit to at the start of deepmind
was the idea of grounded cognition so
this is the idea that well the notion
that a true thinking machine has to be
grounded in a sensory motor data stream
now this kind of gives rise to notions
of end-to-end learning agents you know
the perhaps start with raw vision so it
may be pixels on a screen and go all the
way to making it
vision about what action to take and
we're [ __ ] in that highest back of
things that's involved all the way from
perception to decision-making now
usually when people talk about grounded
cognition on body cognition people start
working on or thinking about robots and
of course that's the ultimate grounding
robots in the real world but actually we
decided to start off with simulations
and specifically games and we think that
games are a pretty perfect platform for
developing and testing AI algorithms
especially these kinds of grounded
algorithms so firstly obviously you can
create unlimited training data by
running the game as much as you like
there's no testing bias because the
games were designed to be challenging to
for humans obviously they were designed
by game designers for the purpose of
entertainment not for testing a is so
often I think one of the things that's
held back the AI field is that usually
is the algorithmic developers who the
algorithm developers who also develop
the tests and that can lead to a kind of
unconscious bias about what the tests
really test for of course compared to
robots you can parallel test these
algorithms you know run millions of
agents at once all playing the games and
it's also quite convenient in most games
that have scores so it's very convenient
for us to measure incremental progress
if you make some small change to an
algorithm you can quickly see and
quantify the difference it's made so we
really love games and of course we also
like robots and we're very interesting
robots as a sort of application of AI
but not at you know in terms of
development we mostly focus on
simulation so I guess our most sort of
widely known work to date is I work on
deep reinforcement learning where I
think we showed for the first time quite
impressive use of the reinforcement
learning when we used it on the classic
Atari games from the 80s Atari 2600
games I'm just going to run a quick
video of some of the of the agent
playing these games but just to be clear
for those you haven't seen this video
before you know what the agents getting
here
are just the raw pixels as inputs around
30,000 pixels per frame and the goal
here is to maximize the score everything
else is learnt from scratch and here
it's a single system we insist on a
single system that plays all the
different games without any tweaking of
the hyper parameters so we called this
system dqn after the cube the deep TV
network and here's a sort of little
medley of the same system playing of a
mere half a dozen games and you can see
for those you don't know about Atari
games how different in style they are
visually also in terms of their
objectives incredibly diverse and and
the same system could you know
effectively master all of these games
now when we sort of published our nature
paper on this we were better than human
at just over half the games and now with
superhuman level at some all but five of
them so if you if you're interested in
there so here's a book the boxing
example where you know here that omits
the red boxer on the left hand side
playing the inbuilt AI and so if you're
interested in the details of this so you
know it's all in the in the nature
article including our code which is
available online so you couldn't you can
play with the EQ and yourself so given
we're here talking about brains and
minds as well as machines what about the
brain and in fact dqn and why one of the
reasons it works so well was partially
inspired by neuroscience and
specifically hippocampal replay the idea
of replaying your experiences so that
you can maximize the use of that
information and that was critical the
use of replay was critical in making vqn
tractable in a reasonable amount of time
when it was training on these games so I
spend the rest of the talk now just
discussing my own view on you know how
systems neuroscience should be
integrated with AI so first two thing to
talk about is you know often I get asked
well why bother with the brain or
neuroscience at all you know there are
probably many other ways of building
intelligence and that might well be true
but I think there's a couple of
arguments to take neuroscience seriously
first of all I think it's likely that
the number of
possible solutions is actually very
small compared to the size of the search
space so if that's actually true
then it's probably worth honing in on
trying to reverse engineer at least to
some extent the solution that we know
exists and after all the brain is the
only existence proof we have that
general intelligence is possible at all
now that might all be very well but if
it would be no point talking about it if
we didn't have amazing now new
techniques and data streams to actually
analyze and to give us information about
what's going on inside the brain and
pretty much yearly now amazing new
techniques get developed so away from
optogenetics kind of tommix two-photon
microscopy you know that the list of
them goes on and on now and you know
there's a huge proliferation now of
amazing techniques to get ever closer to
what's going on in the brain and this is
all resulting in a kind of exponential
increase in our understanding of the
brain of course it's got a long way to
go you know I'm not saying we have a
good full or even close to full
understanding what's happening with the
brain but there are many clues now many
interesting nuggets of information that
if used in the right way I think can be
helpful for AI developments so I see
there's sort of two you know kind of two
buckets if you like of you know the
purpose of neuroscience in terms of how
it can help a eye development so firstly
maybe more obviously it can provide
direction so research direction and
inspiration for new types of algorithms
architectures and even analysis
techniques for analyzing these machine
learning systems and I think we should
be looking to neuroscience where we have
the least idea or the most on certainty
if you like about what to do in machine
learning to solve a particular problem
or to have a particular capability and
also I think something that some we're
pushing very hard on at deepmind is
building and taking a inspiration from
the analysis and visualization tools
that are now quite mature in
neuroscience say for analyzing fMRI
images and then applying that in some
analogous way to analyzing machine
learning systems another interesting
thing is actually the experimental
techniques in
design techniques that are kind of
standard in things like fMRI which in
terms of controlling for what you're
looking for in an experiment and that's
something again that in machine learning
either hasn't come across yet and I
think could be very useful this sort of
idea of designing these kinds of
experiments that we do in neuroscience
the second way I think neuroscience can
can end up being useful is wike or
validation testing so if you have some
idea of our notion of you know your
favorite type of algorithm and maybe
it's reinforcement learning you know and
you're sort of arguing with another
machine learner that actually this
should constitute or could constitute a
viable component of an overall a GI
system you know how much ever had you
decide if this is you know this is a
reasonable conjecture and you know so
maybe you go away and you start trying
to build a system and probably it
doesn't work straight away so then
you've got to decide like how much more
effort should we put into that you know
is it just a question of another few
years and then something viable will
happen and something interesting will
happen so it's very difficult decisions
to be made especially if you're running
a large group or you have a large team
of where should you put your effort and
I think if you can point to a system in
the brain that that analogously does
that sort of mimics that algorithm or or
indeed the algorithm mimics that part of
the brain then I think that can give us
confidence that we should put more
effort into that area of research and
that ultimately it will all yield some
fruit and in fact that's what we thought
about with reinforcement learning and
why we committed to that so heavily
because the brain indeed in most
biological systems use forms of
reinforcement learning like TV learning
in order to learn about their
environment but as you know the next
question then is you know you're going
to take neuroscience seriously there's
so much neuroscience so what parts of
neuroscience should we be paying
attention to and so here I like quoting
sort of David Mars three level analysis
or it should be called Thomas tommy's or
three level analysis well I think Tommy
was involved in heavily in this and
David Marr used to say in the 70s
probably one of the founding fathers of
computational neuroscience that to fully
understand a complex biological system
you need to understand
on three levels the computational level
which is what the what if you like the
goals of the system and algorithmic
level so the how so the representations
and algorithms the system uses and the
implementation level you know ie the
sort of physical substrate that realizes
the system so those are the three levels
you need if you want to fully understand
say the brain but actually I think for
machine learning and AI development
really the top two levels are the most
important so at the mind we focus on the
kind of computation on algorithmic
levels and when we come to analyze
neuroscience in the brain so
collectively I refer to that as systems
neuroscience and really what we're
interested in then Ben is the algorithms
and the representations and the
architectures that the brain uses and
we're working on all sorts of sort of
cutting-edge areas where we're using
systems neuroscience ideas as well as
the course machine learning ideas to try
and make progress on so here's just a
sort of a kind of summary of some of the
areas that we're looking on at the
moment and currently focusing on
representations memory attention concept
planning navigation imagination and in
fact in terms of parts of the brain
Christoph was talking earlier about you
know prefrontal cortex and and and
high-level cortex but actually one of
the old parts of the brain the
hippocampus which is a bit of the brain
in pink here in the middle it turns out
to be quite critical for a lot of these
capabilities so let's talk about some of
those in in order that still talk about
memory first so we've been experimenting
a lot with memory and adding memory to
neural networks so one way you can think
about the work we're doing is you take a
classical computer we implement a
sophisticated recurrent neural network
perhaps with some LS TMS and then we
give it a huge memory store that it can
learn to control and then that whole
system is differentiable end to end and
then what we end up with is what we're
dubbing this neural cheering which
called a new occurring machine in the
sense that it has all the components now
that a Turing machine would need but its
neural and the
that it's learnt by from input and
output examples so here's a sort of
cartoon diagram of the of the
architecture so you've got the in the
center then the CPU the controller is
the recurrent neural network and then
there's the input and output tape you
can think of and it learns by example
input-output examples and it learns to
control this a very large memory store
on the right and learns to read and
write from that now I haven't got time
to go into this in detail today and in
fact I think Alex Graves is giving a
talk on this right at the moment but
also a Greg Wayne is giving a talk about
this at 5 o'clock tomorrow in another
one of the workshops so he'll be going
to much more detail about this work if
you're interested I'm just going to give
it to show you a couple of videos of
sort of some of the latest things we've
been able to do in your tree machines
over the last year so we looked at this
one of these classical problems from
old-fashioned AI I guess back from the
80s shrewd Allu which is a blocked world
problem and the idea is that you're
trying to manipulate these blocks you
know put the green block on the red
block or put the blue pyramid inside the
white box and you can also answer
questions about the scene as well now
we're not ready to tackle full shrewd
ulu yet but we created a kind of mini
version of Shruti Liu if you like so a
mini blocks world where now we're
looking sidon onto this block world and
the sort of task we created was imagine
a configuration of blocks here on the
left you have this starting
configuration and you've got a goal
configuration on the right-hand side and
the system has to convert the start
configuration into the goal
configuration by moving one block at a
time
so the only moves that are allowed are
moving the top block to the block to any
of the columns adjacent columns so it's
a little bit like a complex Tower of
Hanoi problem and it's actually quite
difficult for humans to do in some sort
of you know reasonably optimal way so
I'm just going to run this video and
show you how the Nutri machine does so
in the middle here you see it trying to
change the star configuration into the
goal configuration and no obviously it's
never seen this type of configuration
before so obviously the stock
configuration the goal configuration a
totally new it's
learn this some example seeing other
examples of solutions from other
positions you can see there it's solved
the problem and then we have actually a
language a sort of mini language version
of this where we describe now the
constraints in terms of little language
instructions rather than an example end
board and so we if you see down at the
bottom here I hope you can see that the
little constraint so like blocks we need
to be down from block 5 block 4 needs to
be up from block to block 1 needs to be
up from block 4 and so on and so we give
a bunch of these constraints and then
from the start position the your Turing
machine has to reach an end position
that satisfies all those constraints so
I'll show you that again here so it
reads in the constraints
letter-by-letter
and then when it sees the question mark
it knows that it's supposed to execute
solution so you can see there at the end
there that that final ball configuration
actually satisfies all those constraints
3 down to 5 4 up from 2 1 ups and 4 and
6 down from 3 and it does that in an
inner in a in an optimal way so that's
so what about concepts so we would like
to have abstract concepts because it's
going to be key for so many things
including transfer learning which you
know I think is one of the keys to
flexible general intelligence so we
defined transfer learning is the ability
to apply previously learned knowledge
appropriately to a new situation to help
your performance in that new situation
and that breaks down into at least three
sort of sub steps one is you got to
identify the salient features in your
current environment and more importantly
ignore the irrelevant features then you
need to re represent those features as
an abstract concept so sort of divorced
from the perceptual features that you
learned them in and then once you have
the library of concepts you need to be
able to select and appropriately apply
those to any new situation that you
encounter so probably step two of this
is the probably that I mean all these
things are very challenging but prospect
theory is probably the most challenging
and the most critical and really I think
from the beginning of deepmind we've
identified learning abstract concepts as
one of the keys breakthroughs that are
needed towards getting us to AGI and you
can see this diagram you know this sort
of missing gap on the left-hand side you
know you can think of information in the
brain crudely split into three levels
like perceptual information there's
abstract conceptual information and
finally symbolic information like words
and there's been a lot of work obviously
amazing progress the last decade on with
things like deep learning in terms of
dealing with perceptual information and
obviously there was a lot of work in the
80s on logic networks but there's this
missing piece in the middle which would
allow the symbol to be grounded and also
form to go from perception information
up to truly abstract information now I
think as a Gabriel showed in Gable and
you know when I was in my PhD in
neuroscience in London I was this was
one of the key results that I noticed
that were quite amazing to me in terms
of clues about how the brain might do
this so he's a Jennifer Anniston neurons
I think gate will cover this earlier you
know he's in Europe this is a neuron
that only fires to Jennifer Anniston
pictures and only when she's on her own
not when she's with Brad Pitt so so you
know so this is very specific and here's
a Halle Berry neuron you know where here
it can be you know drawings of her not
particularly good drawings in fact and
you know where one where she's dressed
up as Catwoman so and you know another
one which just heard the text of her
name and so you know these are really
abstract neurons in some sense that are
representing that the concept of Halle
Berry Halle Berry so then you know we've
done a lot experiments I did something
hit my PhD with my colleague Josh and
Kumaran where we looked at conceptual
learning in the brain with fMRI studies
and so in this study here we had a
people learning about fractal patterns
so they saw two fractal patterns on
honest on a on a TV screen and they had
to predict the weather outcome of the
next day whether it be sunny or rainy
and they learned this by trial and error
and eventually you find what you learn
is that there's some underlying pattern
so certain fractals you can ignore where
they're positioned and others other
fractals you can ignore their identity
it's just important where their position
on the screen so these are kind of
underlying rules that were independent
of the fractals themselves and we scan
people learning this task while they
were learning the first task and then
once they mastered that there was a
second task where now we change the
fractals to new fractals but the
underlying rules were the same were kept
the same and we scan them learning the
second task and they were much faster at
learning the second task and what was
really interesting is that the part of
the brain that correlated with this
increased learning in the second task
when we were scanning in the first task
was actually the hippocampus so the
amount of activity in the hippocampus in
the first pass predicted later transfer
to the second task it being improved on
the second task
so it seems quite strong evidence so
then the hippocampus here this is quite
difficult for me to point out it from
the same podium here hippocampus here is
very critical in learning concepts
there's another famous study actually of
them a sleep study also related to
probably hippocampal replay and the
learning of concepts so in this one the
concept we're trying to learn is this
linear hierarchy for a is better than B
that's better than C that a de and F but
you you don't see that whole hierarchy
at once you only see the individual
pairs so you see that you you get shown
B and a together B and C together and so
on and you have to learn by trial and
error which one of the two is better but
you never see the whole hierarchy and
the joins between so your brain kind of
has to infer this from those individual
premise pairs and what's interesting
about this study is that when they did
this and they tested people 20 minutes
later on the separated pairs so maybe
like would be better than B then people
are at charge level 20 minutes later but
after 12 hours or 24 hours and a night
of sleep they're now up to 80% or 90%
successful on the B sort of separated
pairs the influence pairs but even after
20 minutes there's no difference on
remembering the premise pairs so it's
really this in this sort of extraction
of conceptual information that's
happening during the sleep
so what about representations so here's
another thing that I saw that made me
think about this is a huge clue to how
representations are structured in the
brain so there's this very famous effect
in psychology called the drm effect and
what happens here just briefly is that
you get shown as a subject lists of
words so maybe let's take that top list
dark cat white and coal and you get you
get shown all these study words and
you're told to memorize them and then
later you get tested on these words and
you get tested on like did you see the
word cat and you say yes no but there's
also critically similar words so like
here that word black or the word river
or the word cold which are related to
those lit wordless but were not shown
during the study phase and actually
people get em fooled very reliably to
say that they see they've seen the word
black or they've seen the word River
when they didn't actually see it during
the study phase this is an incredibly
reliable effect so it's been known since
the sixties it was rediscovered in the
90s and it's been repeated like you know
in thousands of psychology experiments
one of the most cited studies but
interestingly no one has thought about
doing this with fMRI so what we decided
to do is look at this with fMRI where
now you know you can think about what's
going on in the brain and why is this
happening and one of the reasons we
thought was that a partial priming
effect so the idea is that you know
these the neural representations
underlying these words are maybe
partially overlapping perhaps they were
learned because of the way they were
learned through similar experiences and
we thought maybe the degree of overlap
would predict how how much the brain of
that individual would be fooled into
thinking that they've seen that world
because perhaps all these partial
priming of these partial overlaps would
end up creating a full a priming effect
on the word which is maybe the way the
brain judges whether you've seen
something recently or not and that's
what we found is that actually once we
start the scanning people looking at
these lists leave these word lists and
being tested on a drm effect we found
that afterwards there was one part of
the brain that predicted whether
reliably whether individuals were going
to get confused about whether they saw a
specific word and the part of the brain
that kept that
with predicting that was the anterior
temporal lobes here highlighted in the
yellow and that's actually known to be
the area that's involved in semantic
dementia so that's the part of the brain
that goes wrong when you have semantic
dementia so it's actually where we
predicted these types of conceptual
semantic representations would be and I
think this study now shows a little bit
about how those representations might be
organized so with imagination now then
as a final part you know this is
something I also did in my PhD was
looking at how people imagined and plan
for the future and one thing we decided
to test them was hippocampal patient so
patients without hippocampus as damage
to the hippocampus could they imagine we
know that there are music we know they
don't have episodic memory but they
could they imagine things about the
future and so we tested all these
imaginings like cues like imagine you're
lying on a white sandy beach in a
beautiful tropical Bay describe what you
can see and when we looked at the
patient descriptions there was usually
impoverished specifically in their
spatial coherence so what that means is
that they couldn't bind the disparate
components of a scene into a coherent
whole and you can see their performance
here they're the dark bar this is a
measure of kind of richness of their
description and they're massively
impoverished compared to age and
education matched and verbal matched
controls on the right hand side we then
put this in the scanner and we found
that of course the hippocampus is
critical but there's also a whole brain
Network a very reliable one that
mediates imagination and is also
involved in episodic memory so then one
is anything you can think of and we did
we haven't touched on this is also about
animal intelligence you know there's not
only human intelligence I think we can
also learn a lot from animal
intelligence so I was fascinated to see
whether rats can actually imagine and so
we designed this study but it was quite
elegant and quite simple to show I think
categorically that rats can imagine so
we first of all we looked at play selves
so for those you don't know play cells
or neurons in the hippocampus of the rat
that signal where a rat is in that
location so here we got top-down looking
at box rattles in and then be the two
cells a and B that fire only in that
position in the box what we can also we
also know from previous rat studies is
the sea
these cells play when a rat runs along a
trajectory like a linear track so here
ABCD in the end it replays in the order
that the rat moved in we also know that
when the rat goes to sleep
these trajectories are replayed a very
speeded rates probably to aid learning
so what we did is we designed a teammate
and so now again we're looking top down
the rat there's a barrier on this
teammate that stops the rat reaching the
arms but the barrier see through so the
rat can see the arms it just can't move
there so initially in the first phase
the rat runs up and down the stem of the
teammate and we give it a reward we show
it a reward on the right hand side you
can see the food pellet but it can't
reach it then the rat goes to sleep and
we're recording from the rats brain at
this point and it's very important this
because we this is this is a critical
data that we come back to to analyze
then in the second session we remove the
bat that the the barrier so now the rat
can freely move up and down v teammate
and so now on the arms of the teammates
we can find it play cells so here a and
B and what we find is that when we go
back to this analyze the sleep phase
that in fact these plays cells were
being replayed or pre played if you like
during that sleep even though the rat
had never experienced it yet so it only
it only seen it maybe it was thinking
about moving towards the food pellet so
this is the first time that anyone has
ever shown imagined play cells and what
was very cool was that there were
significantly more pre plays if you like
to the right hand on where the food
pellet was then to the left hand arm in
every one of the four rats so I think
that's pretty categorical that this was
actually behaviorally relevant as well
so we're now looking at imagination
based or model-based planning in for our
Atari agents and this is a very this is
an early version of some of the models
that were trying to build in and use in
planning so I'm just going to end with
integrated agents so if you now combine
all the things I've been talking about
into a single agent then perhaps we have
something that could be deemed rat level
AI so be able to do unsupervised vision
attention have memory episodic memory
navigate round mazes and perhaps even to
imagination based
and I think you know rad is pretty smart
so if we can get to this level that'd be
pretty spectacular and maybe you can
think of the Atari agent as a sort of
lizard level so here's a little sneak
preview the kinds of things we're
working on - this is now true feed 3d
environments called labyrinth this we've
extended it from an open source 3d
engine and this is our agent navigating
around finding rewarding apples and and
also exits out of the maze just form
pixel inputs so just from from the raw
pixels so we run doubling down on
systems neuroscience at deep mind and I
think there's an incredible wealth of
information and ideas and clues if you
look you know where to look and I think
we're actually just at the beginning of
the influence of neuroscience and AI on
each other and one thing we're
especially excited about is developing
new tools and techniques borrowed from
neuroscience to help with the analysis
of machine learning systems so I think
we're sort of entering a very exciting
year in our and we're doubling down on
these efforts and part of that is
actually I'm you know very excited to
announce that Professor Matt Botvinnik
who many of you know from Princeton is
joining us full time from February to
head up the neuroscience team and join
our incredible sort in-house team and
you'll know a lot of his work I'm sure
already from decision making control and
working memory and we also have a bunch
of collaborations with Oxford and of
course MIT with CBMM program Harvard UCL
and so on and obviously we're expanding
the neuroscience team we're putting more
into this so if you're interested in to
what some of the work I've been talking
about then come and have a chat with me
or Matt so I'm just going to end by
saying you know that actually we've
talked a lot about how neuroscience can
help AI but I also think equally
interesting maybe we can discuss in the
panel is how AOA might help us better
understand the human mind especially
questions like their crisp office
interested in like what actually is
consciousness and is it necessary for
example for intelligence and as Richard
Fineman one of my all-time period said
what I cannot build I do not truly
understand and I think that's true of
intelligence - thanks
thanks a lot Berman we have time for a
few questions so thanks for great book
and I was intrigued by your you guys are
now looking at imagination based
planning I guess one of the problems you
have with that kind of system is how
does the agent an agent who acts how's
it know when it's thinking about
something that it's not currently doing
versus when when it should be thinking
about things that it is actually doing
and it seems like in humans at least we
have some sort of cognitive level access
to our own sort of attentional
mechanisms so we know what we're
thinking about and we know that's the
context and why we're thinking about it
you know in space and time so if I think
about my my birthday a few days ago and
I'm not thinking about you know I'm not
confused in that sense yeah sure I mean
we work of attention both to sort of
internal and external tension I think
that's going to be very important I
think you know actually the biggest
issue with our model based planning
stuff is and what our our genitive
models are pretty good so if you measure
them on compression or other things
measures but the small errors compound
very quickly and so if you're trying to
imagine you know hundreds of steps out
the errors get quite large I think part
of the issue is is probably you know you
don't want to actually be imagining on
the pixel level ideally you want to be
sort of measure you know imagining on
some high level feature level which
again comes back to sort of concepts so
let's say that's the bigger problem then
not knowing whether you're imagining or
not I mean in an artificial system we
can make that distinction quite clear
does that work yesterday a quick comment
and the question you mentioned in the
beginning of this blocks well problems
that you and Heidi met are you doing
that very well we're able to solve and
you also mentioned that you think such
as a more complex version of citizen
away problem I think that's not the case
simply because in the cause of an oil
problem us is additional constraint
where you cannot place a larger disc on
a smaller one which means that if your
Zen discs you really need to to to to
the N move which means if you are
to this you need a billion move through
solve the problem optimally which is not
the case and that particular reduced
blackboard setting what is maybe more
important for the topic of the symposium
is in the beginning you mentioned that
you were inspired by neuroscience as you
did the Atty again that a thing and and
you mentioned the action replay as an
example but that of course goes back to
Lynne 1991 aware that PhD thesis on the
important learning about some action
replay and which we could do it with
your class yeah you're close guys yes
that's better later
and the point is however is that this
was driven by engineering considerations
and so the question do you have
something where you really can show
neuroscience inspired us to do something
better than standard engineering which
would maybe address exactly vibrating um
that's a very difficult bar because I
think what you'll find is that
neuroscience ideas are sort of seeping
around everywhere and help formulate
certain ideas and of course you should
be doing both at the same time so I
think engineering should go hand in hand
with the neuroscience and lots of ideas
have been thought of in machine learning
and lots in the neuroscience and I think
it helps they help each other sort of
confirm that you're going in the right
direction I mean even comp nets with you
know Hubel and Wiesel you know which
ones influenced who I mean I'm sure you
know you could say that the ComNet sort
of came up you know with little
influence from that but actually I think
these ideas are kind of all mixing
together and help with this progress so
I don't know if you were asking for
specific example of exactly a
neuroscience thing that was done and
then interpreted in machine learning is
that we were saying well continent is
actually a great example because that
was in my point of view more or less the
last time when your science really
produced an important inspiration for AI
which because Fukushima's convolutional
networks and the 70s were inspired by
Whoville and weasels resurgence of the
50s yeah
good question for the panel autumn and
other people might comment so let's do
this better and menu one two quick
questions we're here I try to be very
quick I'm surprised that you rule out
innate structure more or less altogether
and I wonder whether that's a
methodological commitment you said at
the beginning you want to do everything
kind of from raw pixels you don't want
anything built in there's a lot of
evidence from biology that the genome is
spending half of its effort so to speak
trying to build a very carefully
structured way and so why not as I'm
sure so in fact I should clarify that so
we're injured in sort of learning as far
as possible sort of end to end but we're
not at we're not against having modules
or I mean clearly evolution has given
some initial constraints so we're
looking at those kinds of things as well
but we would like the prior knowledge
that we build in to be as minimal as
possible and as generic as possible
that's maybe another longer way of
saying it the empirical question with
the right amount should be so yeah very
brief collaboration and competition have
some neural basis in the frontal cortex
so like this agents are very independent
what role do you think competition and
collaboration play between learning
systems so we arranged in things like
meta control where where there's you
know more than one type of control
system and then you've got to decide
which system to trust or which system to
switch to so the brain you know
definitely does that between mobile free
model-based perhaps between episodic
controllers as well so we're looking at
that and you know implementing something
similar to that may be you know deciding
around the uncertainty of each of the
controllers so we're looking at that
moment Oh should say thanks to all my
colleagues of course to deep mind all
the making people have done all the work
on on the screen here and many more
thanks thanks thanks I'm once again
[Applause]